Disney's added again and this time
around they've got a master director
pulling all the strings Dumbo is set to
come out in theaters in March of 2019
and countless fans are starting to
bubble with excitement watch until the
end to find out why this remake will
have you crying all for the right
reasons all about Dumbo some Disney
movies become classics overnight and
others feed into the background until
they're brought back to life well anyone
who's seen Dumbo knows that it's not an
easy movie to watch especially since
there are many sad themes surrounding
its plot well it's time to go out with
the old and in with the new
which is why Disney's latest remake is
going to delight us in more ways than
one
if anyone had told us that Dumbo would
be getting a live-action remake ten
years ago we would have told them that
we'd believe it when pigs could fly but
for the first time being it looks like
elephants are the only ones who will be
taking flight anytime soon it's been 78
years since the original Dumbo movie was
released so it goes without saying that
much of its story will change the old
Dumbo was a cartoon character who could
speak to his best friend Timothy the
mouse the new Dumbo will be nothing of
the sort what to expect many of us don't
know what to expect from the newest
Dumbo film and how could we
after all the movie follows a talking
elephant who's constantly ridiculed by
those closest to him but before you go
and write this movie off here's why you
should be the first in line to buy a
ticket
unlike Disney's Beauty and the Beast
Live remake Dumbo's plot has been
rewritten in its entirety this means
that there will be a few similarities
between the 1941 version and it's 2019
counterpart so no you won't be watching
an HD version of a film you've seen one
too many times before instead you'll be
introduced to new characters beautiful
cinematography and an eerie but tasteful
soundtrack better yet you'll get to
feast your eyes on the cutest animated
elephant you've ever seen in your life
the original versus the remake although
the original Dumbo and its live-action
remake might share a name these two
productions have more differences than
we can count the original movie is told
from Dumbo's point of view which is only
normal considering that he's the film's
protagonist
perhaps the biggest difference between
these two movies is that Dumbo will be
stepping back to make way for character
hold barrier who will be posing as the
film's leading man the 1941 Disney flick
follows Dumbo's journey as he learns how
to become his circuses main attraction
however it looks like the remake will
focus on Dumbo gaining his freedom and
finding a sense of family instead while
Timothy the mouse is still present in
the plot he won't be taking his original
spot as the movie's deuteragonist
instead both children will be stealing
the show and showering Dumbo with lots
of love from what we've seen in the
trailer it looks like the live-action
remake will showcase Dumbo's abilities
from the get-go this is a huge
alteration to the original movie's plot
considering the entire film revolved
around Dumbo proving to others that he
was able to fly all in all it looks like
the 2019 Stumbo is following a whole new
direction and that's not necessarily a
bad thing
exciting posters there's nothing like a
good old movie poster to get us in the
mood for a motion picture and Dumbo's
posters aren't one to disappoint
first off Dumbo looks absolutely
adorable and his big blue I somehow
managed to steer the attention away from
his ears the elephant looks nothing like
his older version and that's to be
expected next on the list is Michael
Keaton who is said to play the bad guy
his poster shows hints of his terrifying
personality proving that he's not going
down without a fight
although Danny DeVito is set to play a
bad guy as well his poster shows no
hints of malice but oddly enough this is
fitting to his character's personality
after all an angry circus owner isn't
going to sell many tickets on a lighter
note actor Colin Farrell's poster
resembles one of a true American Hero
his eyes are fixed upwards in a hopeful
manner which is why many of us are
hoping that Dumbo's ending will be a
happy one and last but not least is the
gorgeous Eva green the actresses poster
appears to be putting on a show however
her eyes are slightly dulled giving us
the notion that she does not enjoy being
an entertainer whoever said that a
picture is worth a thousand words wasn't
kidding after all every single one of
these posters seems to be saying a story
of their own it's directed by the
legendary Tim Burton just when we
thought that Dumbo couldn't sound any
more promising we find out that the
legendary Tim
Burton will be directing and producing
the film when it comes to directing kids
movies tim is one of the best in the
business
tim is known for directing movies like
Beetlejuice Edward Scissorhands and
Alice in Wonderland so we can only
expect him to bring his gothic cinematic
style to the film Tim's style is so
unique and inviting that he's managed to
create his own special genre one look at
Dumbo's teaser trailer is all you need
to see to realize that it was made to
follow a similar burton-esque fashion so
if you were on the fence about Disney's
new Dumbo and the fact that Tim is
directing the film should be enough to
tip you over to the other side its cast
is jam-packed with big stars you know a
movie is going to be great when a string
of well-known actors joined the
production a handful of award-winning
celebrities are bringing their magic to
the 2019 live-action remake so why not
take a look at which characters they'll
be per trained Colin Farrell as Holt
barrier Colin Farrell is an actor who's
well known for playing in movies like
the lobster Horrible Bosses and
fantastic beasts and where to find them
he's been cast as holt barrier a former
circus star who's been hired to look
after Dumbo both story begins after
returning home from World War one the
war has made him an amputee so going
back to his old job is simply out of the
question
Holt and his children become Dumbo's
number one pals and before long he
becomes part of their family
Ava green as Colette merchant for now
little is known about Ava Green's
character Colette however we do know
that she's a famous aerial artist who
loves being in the spotlight Colette and
Dumbo eventually become co-stars in an
act but we'll have to wait and find out
which side Colette is really on eva is
well known for playing miss Peregrine's
in the hit movie Miss Pentagon's Home
for peculiar children so we're excited
to see what the acclaimed actress has in
store for us now Danny DeVito as max
Medici is there anyone on this earth who
doesn't know who Danny DeVito is we
highly doubt it
this oscar-winning actor is set to play
circus owner max Medici this character
is quick to make an extra buck and he
doesn't care who you hurts to earn it
Max's persona is loosely based off of
the nameless ringmaster from the
original Dumbo movie and in the
live-action remake we'll see how far max
is willing to go to save his struggling
circus business for the time being this
character has been labeled as a bad guy
Michael Keaton as VA Xander fear every
movie needs an antagonist and in this
case it's none other than the renowned
actor Michael Keaton he's set to play
the conniving VA VanDerveer a famous
recruiter who'll stop at nothing to own
the latest attraction from what we've
seen so far it looks like van Devere has
his sights set on poor Dumbo and there's
no way of knowing his evil tactics will
prevail a sequel vibe elephants are
beautiful and intelligent animals who
don't deserve to be bred into captivity
however mini circuses see fit to keep
them around back in 1941 it was normal
for circuses to have such gigantic
mammals
however times have changed and so of
animal rights so it's only normal for
the 2019 version of Dumbo to end on a
very different note than the film that
came before it
the original Dumbo ends with the little
elephant becoming a Love circus act but
we want something different for our
favorite big yard elephant so although
this movie is labeled as a remake many
of us feel as though it's a sequel for
starters
Dumbo's journey isn't going to end when
he becomes accepted by those around him
this is because he learns to fly at the
beginning of the movie and not the
ending so by default the remake begins
where the original left off this way we
could see what happens to Dumbo after he
becomes a big star and as the trailer
depicts Dumbo's journey won't be an easy
one with the help of holt and his two
children Dumbo will perhaps find freedom
after escaping from van de beers evil
clutches the old crew returns there are
so many reasons to be excited about
Disney's latest remake and here's one of
them it's not the cast's first time
working together back in 1992 Tim Burton
directed the movie Batman Returns and
actors Michael Keane and Danny DeVito
snatched up the leading roles under
Tim's guidance Michael was turned into a
superhero and Danny into a villain and
now 27 years later all three stars are
joining forces to bring us another
classic film however it seems as though
their roles will be reversed instead of
playing a vigilante like Batman Michael
is taking on the role of the big bad and
he seems very happy about it
during an interview with Good Morning
America Michael opened up about how
excited he was to be playing a villain
however the actor confessed about being
mostly excited to join Tim's crew once
more so there you have it guys
history
is in the making a heart-wrenching tale
with a golden message there's a reason
why Disney is remaking Dumbo and it has
nothing to do with box-office revenue
okay well maybe it has a little to do
with that but for the most part Disney
wants to bring back Dumbo's classic
message which is to believe in yourself
despite what others think
Dumbo story is definitely a tearjerker
which is why it's often compared to
Bambi however there is something special
about the storyline and it has
everything to do with a little black
feather in the original film Dumbo and
Timothy wake up in a tree after a night
of good fun and their confusion makes a
murder of crows laugh out loud
despite not having any memories of the
night before Dumbo is certain that he
must have blown up the tree so when a
Crow's feather floats down to him he
holds it out as a beacon of hope flash
forward to the remake and the scene
black feather teaches Dumbo how to fly
despite the fact that the black feather
came from a crow who was mocking him
Dumbo used it as fuel to achieve his
dreams so in a way this black feather is
very symbolic
although the newest Dumbo film might
still succeed at making us shed a tear
or two it also teaches us to turn our
weaknesses into strengths
so are you guys excited to watch this
live-action remake let us know how you
feel about it in the comments section
below and that's the end of our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the theme
[Music]